cette énorme presse à 75 ans et elle
vient de l'usine originale de Dave
Hélène à Toronto ici on est dans la
durée et le long terme
une pression de plus de 300 bars
John punch nous montre fièrement une des
dizaines de milliers de pièces d'un
bombardier d'eau qui ira quelque part
dans le fuselage
c'est ici à Victoria dans la filiale
Viking que se fabrique toutes les pièces
des avions de DA V Land et entre autres
des fameux canadaires dont les droits
ont été rachetés en 2016 à Bombardier
des pièces de rechange pour des
appareils qui ont parfois plus de 40 ans
et maintenant les toutes premières
pièces du nouveau DHC 515 le successeur
des cl215 et 415
c'est ici dans ces structures que seront
sous peu monter les éléments de
carlingue du 515 qui seront envoyés
ensuite pour assemblage final à Calgary
85% des pièces du 515 seront les mêmes
que ces prédécesseurs les 215 et les 415
dit le vice-président Nils winet on ne
veut pas réinventer la roue nous voulons
améliorer quelque chose qui fonctionne
déjà très bien des donc en position de
produire le nouvel avion dans des
conditions idéales les Canada ont connu
beaucoup de succès la demande est très
forte maintenant alors que le climat
continue à changer pouvoir produire à
nouveau un avion qui a déjà eu du succès
nous permet de le mettre sur le marché
plus rapidement que s'il fallait
l'inventer complètement malgré ça ce ne
sera pas facile d'obtenir de nouveaux
515 alors que des feux de forêt
exceptionnelles dans un contexte évident
de réchauffement climatique révèle une
grande pénurie de bombardiers d'eau
[Musique]
les 22 premiers DHC 515 iront à 6 pays
de l'Union européenne plus 2 à la France
et 6 pour l'Indonésie premier livraison
c'est la terrible saison d'incendie de
2017 qui a poussé les Européens à passer
leurs commandes mais il a fallu attendre
les lettres d'intention en 2022 pour que
da vilains sont 515
le contrat final n'est même pas encore
signé il devrait l'être prochainement
c'est clair le Canada le Québec ont été
négligent et aurait dû augmenter leur
flotte d'avion citerne plutôt la liste
d'attente risque d'être longue pour des
livraisons bien au-delà de 2030 en
attendant une option consistera à
moderniser les appareils les plus vieux
sur la flotte de 14 canadairs du Québec
4 au moins on aurait besoin l'opération
prend de 12 à 18 mois
en 2017 des vilaine avait à Calgary 11
appareils 215 et 415 récupérer ici et là
ils ont été réparés et modernisés des
turbos propulseurs remplaçant les vieux
moteurs à piston cinq d'entre eux ont
été revendus au Montana et ils ont été
prêtés en ce moment même au Québec
les canadairs ont des concurrents le
biracteur Russe Beriev 200 de vieux
avions commerciaux recyclés comme le 747
ou des décès 10 le nouvel avion
militaire à Airbus 400
mais aucun ne semble pouvoir remplacer
les canadairs qui déversent au moins
deux fois plus d'eau que les autres 700
tonnes par jour sur les terrains les
plus difficiles
il existe bien un projet belge
prometteur le sigo mais sur papier
seulement donc loin de la production oui
415 et le nouveau 5015 sont le standard
des bombardiers d'eau qui permettent
d'articuler autour d'eux tout un
programme de lutte contre les incendies
ce sont les appareils à toute épreuve
des pompiers du monde entier
c'est l'approche des Européens qui ont
mis une partie de leur flotte en commun
pour répondre plus rapidement aux
urgences les provinces entraident bien
mais le Canada devrait mieux se
coordonner
tout le monde a besoin d'infrastructures
et d'appareils supplémentaires faut-il
un programme national de bombardier
d'eau ou bien plus d'avion pour chaque
province peut-être mais les politiciens
doivent décider
[Musique]
les chiffres sont secrets mais le 515
est cher probablement dans les 50
millions de dollars les pilotes et les
techniciens sont rares les chers opérés
aussi mais ils le sont tous le 515 offre
une meilleure avioni que ses
prédécesseurs et une climatisation plus
efficace importante pour les pilotes
cet avion conçu au Québec ressuscitera
Calgary mais les moteurs prêtés Whitney
seront encore produits à Montréal des
avelling continuera à assurer la
maintenance de tous les appareils et à
garantir les pièces de rechange
d'environ 300 avions dans les 20
prochaines années
son équipe sont en route pour le Salon
aéronautique du Bourget il s'attendent à
y être très occupé
Jean-Michel Leprince Radio-Canada
Victoria